Chris Mannix Sports Illustrated senior
NBA and boxing writer he joins us on the
program from Mexico what are you doing
in Mexico part of the zone broadcast
team on Saturday Dan for the fight that
got down there that I'm back to Boston
poster class and what's the fight what's
the the big fight the fight this weekend
is - lugia and Dennis Hogan but the big
fight coming up is Canelo Alvarez back
in the rink at Danny get fat
that's on May 4th andhe's owned a lot of
boxes in a couple of months ok Loman
chenko this weekend as well right yeah
he's fighting tonight and it's not a
great fight because the guy he's facing
Anthony Crowell is just you know the
kind of guy he has to fight as a
mandatory to defend his title but any
time one would think of like I mean the
guy is number one pound per pound in the
world well the great fighters of all
time because he's running into the
problem that a lot of boxers have in and
what is always a fractured sport and
that is opponents there are guys out
there he could fight but the politics of
boxing make it difficult but make no
fight ever been ringside and got blood
on you all the gun I'm in my capacity
now working with the zone like I'm
sitting right there that literal
ringside position and I could text you
pictures of my notebooks with with blood
spots on them from the last couple of
shows and but it happens pretty
frequently what do you do when you get
blood on yourself it's kind of like a
badge of honor no like I've been in the
trenches like I think I do take pictures
of a notebook paper and you know I don't
know any play it's almost like I was in
the fight but I really was in the fight
so it kind of adds to the atmosphere I
think it's the event you ever been
knocked over in an NBA game like
courtside I don't know where you where
you sit during an NBA game back in the
day before teams kind of realized that
selling the seats that the media sat in
was fat
a way of doing it I've had guys kind of
jump into the press section in that
first couple of rows remember even at
Madison Square Garden used to be great
they put the press right there along the
visitors bench but you know then all of
a sudden they realized that they could
make you know tens of thousands of
dollars selling those seats and they
kick the media upstairs into the halo
section there of the guard and that's
the kind of case across the league
there's still something especially in a
smaller market to put the media need at
or near courtside but more and more
you're seeing the media move forward
further and further off the floor I'll
get into the Lakers here in a moment
give me the two teams that you think can
beat the Golden State Warriors this year
I don't think anybody can honestly okay
and the you know I would think about
this as I was kind of working on some
final stuff you know last year Dan what
are we talking about we were talking
about Stefan Curry's injury and how that
might affect the team in the playoffs
and we were talking about kind of that
regular-season malaise that they went
through as potentially being a precursor
for something bad happening to that team
in the playoffs but that make a lot of
them now they strung a little bit with
Houston a lot really before the seven
games but then they roll through
Cleveland in the NBA Finals
this year it kind of feels like deja vu
I mean we're we're talking about Kevin
Durant's free agency and DeMarcus
Cousins how he's gonna fit I mean these
are minor minor things on the back of a
juggernaut so I think they could get a
scare or be forced to go deep into at
least one series but it's impossible to
think that anybody's gonna take them in
four out of seven I think they'll get up
it it I think they'll get a much tougher
challenge in the finals this year
regardless who comes out of the East
then they would make it last year
against Cleveland yeah but they could
have easily lost last year Chris I mean
if if Houston acts like Houston in the
seventh game and Chris Paul acts like
Chris Paul and done get heard they're
winning and they're going to the NBA
Finals and probably winning the
championship here so I don't think you
can look at it go
hey you know they had a little bit of a
scare they should have lost I mean they
could have lost I think I mean the Chris
Paul injury sealed it for Houston but
you know you can't look at the Rockets
and say well if only they hadn't missed
37 threes in that game 7 they would have
won what part again like the next shot
and you can go wonderful with a lot of
things so yeah I mean I think the rocket
will still be tough I don't think
they're quite as strong as they were
last year with trevor ariza in that mix
but I still I'm not buying anybody
beaten gold with a 4 to 70 if it's the
golden papers the field debate I'm
putting all my money uncle Chris Mannix
Sports Illustrated senior NBA and boxing
writer also he has a new show on Sports
Illustrated in the paint just launched
and can be seen every Tuesday his first
guest who's the Commissioner Adam Silver
all right the Lakers mess here what the
hell happened the other day
and what happens moving forward with
this franchise well it's still you know
the more people you talk to in and
around the Lakers organization the more
you get the sense that what it was is
what it is and what I mean by that is
Magic Johnson wasn't holding anything
back when he articulated why he was
walking away from that team and if
you're familiar with the history of
Magic Johnson though you are you covered
him extensively as a player in the 90s
you know in 1994 he quit coaching
because he kind of didn't feel like
doing it anymore didn't like the
challenge of it 1998 that you know
terrible TV show he did you know he quit
back in the aftermath all you heard
about was how you know he wasn't
committed to it and the show was a
disaster start to finish it's a lot of
work to be an NBA executive a top-level
NBA executive it's not just kind of
sitting back watching games making picks
and waiting for free agents to want to
flock to you you kind of hop on planes
and go south the neck Yanis in grease
you've got to go to low-level college
games to find the next Kyle couse the
next great second-round pick that that
flushes out your roster
I don't think and this is based on a few
conversations I've had
I just don't think magic had the heart
for it and has a desire to do it in the
daily basis and you know we can have a
different conversation about the lunacy
of going out there and quitting without
telling your boss or anybody in the
organization the
sanity of getting in a three-hour
meeting the day before and not
articulating at all that you might not
be part of the scheme going forward
that's a separate conversation but why
he quit I just think I didn't want to do
anymore
he decided it's more fun just being
Magic Johnson there's something else to
this story Chris there has to be you
don't have a three-hour meeting and then
all of a sudden go down the elevator and
go you know I think I'm gonna quit yeah
it just doesn't happen there has to be
something else going on I don't know I
mean you heard the speculation I haven't
been able to figure out exactly what is
true and what's not true with this
report about some kind of ESPN story
about something going on behind the
scenes out there maybe there's something
to it but even if there there was Dan
that might explain the abruptness of the
decision to quit because you know nobody
was clamoring for Magic Johnson's job I
mean he hadn't been great at that job
but he wasn't you know leave the
relators in disrepair here but
ultimately whether it was the way quick
or 20 quick I think did quit because he
didn't want to do anymore and that's it
that's based a lot on his history what
we know about magic John all right
moving forward it is Luke Walton gonna
keep his job I think it all depends on
who the next you know passable
operations is there right now Rob
polenka is taking on a bigger role but
I've been told there's nothing decided
yet as far as who is going to be running
the Lakers long term I mean everybody
around the league that has an opinion on
this says the Lakers need to go outside
the organization to find somebody not
within the Laker family I mean this is a
team game with infinite resources I mean
they can afford to pay like 20 million
dollars for an executive they want to do
that if it means giving up a first-round
pick for executives they can do that I
mean they are well equipped to go after
the top guy look I would make every
phone call you have to make I would try
to get Sam Presti out of Oklahoma City
Sam price he's built something there he
wouldn't be leaving Oklahoma City in a
bad place because Paul George there
Russell Westbrook are connecting
long-term contracts I would try Bob
Myers got a UCLA connection this might
be a good time for Bob Myers to move on
with Kevin Durant potentially leaving
and maybe having to overhaul that roster
a little bit I would even call RC Buford
in San Antonio everybody else that kind
of assumes that RC Buford is this San
Antonio Spurs lifer has anybody even
asked him the tribe if he wanted to run
his own operation and try something new
somewhere else with all the resources of
the Lakers I would go big-game hunting
if I was Jeanie buss and not let money
or trap consideration stop me from
getting my guy best first round match-up
in the playoffs is meaningful I think
that's been at a different way because I
don't know that how many great first
round matchups there are most meaningful
Portland Oklahoma City a portland 15
everybody wants to play because the
newark itch injury and and the week and
how the weakens them if oklahoma city
can't get out of the first round against
a portland team that is down a
significant player they've got some real
long-term problems i mean last year's
you kind of gave them a mulligan because
the carmelo stuff Paul George's first
year this year though for most of the
season they look like a contender the
last month or two of the year the
shooting percentage fell off a cliff
they didn't look like the same team this
is a team with a top 10 ish level
defense two superstars
you've got to gather the first round so
that's the one I think I'm watching
closely because it may have the most
long-term impact MVP this year will be a
body for Yanis it's not really that
close to my mind I mean James Harden
awesome
Paul George great yeah go down the list
but Yanis from start to finish Dan I
don't know how the other side also got
my vote for Defensive Player of the Year
so that's that's the factor it as well
Yanis is not just a ridiculous offensive
player with what he did this year but I
think he's the best defensive player in
the league and you know those reasons
getting my vote yeah this is what I said
to Adrienne will turn around skating
said if the Greek freak had won the MVP
last year who would be your MVP this
year would he go back-to-back
probably probably one thing that weighs
on me as I make this decision is you
know I know the Chris Paul missed a
bunch of games this year but he played
58 games and he was around for for you
know most of the season the difference
between Yanis and the second best player
on Milwaukee is this is the gap it's
bigger than other MVP candidates and
their second best player I'm talking
about hard and Paul Paul George and
Westbrook
Kawhi Leonard and and Kyle Lowry go down
the list there's just you know Kevin
Durant and Steph Curry you know Chris
Mills was a good player
it's an old star player he was an
all-star okay but with that book team
make the playoffs without Yanis would
the Rockets make the playoffs without
harden with Chris Paul yes I think they
make the playoffs yeah but you had maybe
yeah I think you're honest is gonna win
it but I disagree if the honest he'd won
it last year then people would have
given it to James Harden this year you
guys are predictable you new voters are
predictable you are predictability is
the right thing to do I mean I mean the
guy is a great defensive player who you
know the team I think finish number one
in defensive rating and Yannick plays
like 35 40 minutes every single night
and he can defend every position
how many guys miss League I mean really
go there is a stopper in the middle and
you know but how many guys in this
league can defend five and one in the
way that Yanis can do it I don't know of
anybody thank you Chris always great to
talk to you
you got a dent that's Chris Mannix
Sports Illustrated NBA boxing letter I
think he's offended that I ended the
conversation there instead of going a
well put there for more Dan Patrick show
tune in to audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV streamed for free on be our live
or download the Dan Patrick show app